Welcome back everyone it's Charlie Netflix
just dropped The Witcher season 3 trailer so
we'll break it down I'll explain what's going on
obviously they're splitting the season and this is
meant to be Henry cavill's last season as Gerald
so we know there's a lot of confusion if you're
brand new to the channel be sure to subscribe
to get all the videos it's still Eight Episodes
they're announcing that the first half of the
Season like the first five episodes will release
June 29th then the last three episodes were
released a month later July 27th they did the same
thing with stranger things season four last year
most of the plot is supposed to adapt The Blood
of Elves book but they changed a lot of the plot
from the books for season two they'll probably
do the same thing for Blood of Elves during season
three also having to change what happens to geralt
to explain how he winds up turning into Liam
Hemsworth pretty big change the showrunner said
that they would explain what's actually going
on with that because it is pretty crazy they
start with geralt entering this building drinking
his Witcher potions and getting ready to draw his
sword to fight what seems like another version of
Rience they did recast the Rience character so I
do think the person that he's fine hiding during
the different parts of the trailer it's just that
recast version of the character just because of
the way he's burned they show the fire behind him
just to let you know that it is probably Ryan's
in his voice over he starts talking about how he's
feeling fear real fear for the first time that's
because he's actually grown to care about Ciri
like he thinks of her as a surrogate daughter
usually when Fearless characters like geralt
start to feel fear is when they grow to care about
other people and those other people wind up in
danger about to die so in his voice over geralt
is saying I get it now like I understand what it
is to be afraid but he's mostly afraid for other
people like Ciri there's a scene of Ciri riding
away from Eredin and the wild Hunt who are on
the main planet now it seems like they've found
a way to cross over but you see the billowy smoke
behind them so I think this is just a version of
them doing the story from the games in the books
the whole idea is that the wild Hunt is stuck in
that other planet but they find ways occasionally
to make it to the main Planet all these black
clouds all the armor this fearsome look their
voices it's all smoke and mirrors we actually
got some of Eredins' backstory during The Witcher
blood origin I'll link my videos for that because
the series was kind of raw like people were not
big fans of the series but they did explain what
their TV show version of aeroton's backstory was
obviously some changes from the books for that as
well too because in the books they don't really
get too much into his backstory so it was them
sort of filling in a lot of gaps with the TV show
this is a new scene of riots walking out of what
seems like a room that he set on fire it also kind
of seems like he's holding a little cat here yes
Gear with what seems like a sorceress that also
seems like she wants to kill him Ciri seemingly
killing someone and then geralt versus Rience I
can't totally tell who yennefer is fighting in
this scene here those might be elves behind her
then they have this larger scene of series stuck
in this giant hedge maze by herself separated from
geralt and Yennefer calling for them it seems like
she faces another giant monster on her own her
power might get out of control again one of the
bigger changes during season two was Yennefer
trying to kill Ciri to get her powers back they
did say that their way of walking that back up
Yennefer trying to mend her relationship with
geralt because geralt isn't a huge fan of hers
right now was them doing the dear friend letters
from the books which is them basically writing to
each other and slowly repairing their relationship
and her talking to him through those letters
and it seems like the white Frost Villain at
least the way they change things during the blood
origin series is manipulating everyone like even
manipulating iridin the wild Hunt because they
want more chaos magic like the whole idea is they
just absorb Magic from other powerful beings and
I think part of the idea is that the Arid world is
other world that Eredin is stranded on used to be
green and Lush but this other person absorbed all
the power there and turned it into an arid world
and now she's going to come to the main world and
do the same thing to it and that's going to be
the Fulfillment of ithlean's ultimate prophecy
the prophecy about her defeating the white Frost
that you see in the books and the games which is
where we get to a bunch of our changes I think
part of the idea is that they wanted Ciri to
have a fight at the end of the show like whatever
the final season is with the white frost feeding
in but her fighting an actual person instead of
just like fighting a giant white cloud of winter
because in the books and the games the way they
personify the white frost is more like a force
of nature like there's no actual Consciousness to
it the way the TV show is setting it up it might
wind up being an actual person who's just another
time traveler pretending to be someone else like
why does the white frost speak with a Scottish
accent in the exact same language that Eredin and
all the other Elven characters can understand if
it's not another Elven character from their race
that's been time traveling but in that Witcher
season 3 post-credits scene avalak uses the book
of monoliths that he's stolen from Baylor to
time travel back to the events of season one
of the main show before Ciri had met geralt before
Emperor emhyrhad shown up her father Sack Cintra
at a bid to try and recapture her so avalock
isn't meant to be really evil the same way that
a lot of the other characters seem like they're
evil like Emperor Emhyr the white frost villain
aired in the wild Hunt but to be fair there is
no real main villain on The Witcher like the
white frost is technically meant to be like the
biggest villain one but everyone on the show is
meant to be low grade kind of a terrible person so
it's like a bunch of terrible people trying to do
what they think is right all going up against
each other with differing opinions on things
so you have Ciri Stuck in the Middle she's this
Ultra powerful being who isn't totally capable of
Defending herself yet geralt who's trying to help
her survive and then all these other factions that
just want her for their own reasons avalak for
example is one of those different factions her
father Emperor Emhyr wants to use her power to
help conquer the rest of the continent because
he's been doing that for the past couple of years
in the background of the show like he's slowly
been conquering all the other Realms vilgaforce
who's also one of the antagonists wants her
power to have another child to fulfill this big
prophecy that will give birth to an even more
powerful child that he can control Eredin and the
wild Hunt want her so they can open as many gates
as they want Between Worlds conquering them across
time and space because he's basically stranded on
this other arid world and they need her power
to open the gates again so that he can travel
between worlds there are space units corns in the
universe of The Witcher that can open Gates the
way that Ciri does but aired in across time across
the hundreds and hundreds of years up to present
day has wound up killing all them off using them
to travel between worlds so that's why he needs
Ciri now because there are no more space unicorns
for him to kill we'll see how the show addresses
that avlack also wants Ciri but his stance on her
changes throughout his story like he seems like
kind of an antagonist later on but he actually
winds up helping her defeat the white Frost
where we see him here staring at her he's at the
beginning of his story he's a little more naive
about things you have to imagine a couple hundred
years later he'll be a little bit more bittered
about all this stuff The Witcher season 3 episode
1 is titled Sherwood it's an ancient Elven Palace
in this area of forest that's sacred to the elves
that was this big fortress to them about 200 years
ago before it was destroyed by humans it means
that during episode 1 geralt and Ciri are going to
be riding through it like they were in The Blood
of Elves book and Blood of Elves is the book that
they're largely adapting for the story of season
three Legacy with some changes the title of Blood
of Elves is also a reference to series Elder blood
because does it is Elven but it started with the
elves she is part elf the title is also reference
to the dying of the elves the fate of the elves
losing their battle fighting with Emperor emhyrthe
other humans in the continent they're slowly dying
out and that was part of the Jazz gear in the mini
driver scenes during blood origin she said that
she wanted him to recite the tale of the seven the
origin of the Elder blood the wild Hunt the white
Frost the order of witchers in order to inspire
The Elves and within the elves you have a group
of them that wants to live peacefully and leave
the humans alone and just kind of continue living
out their lives slowly dying out and then another
group of them that's more militant and wants to
kill all the humans when he goes back at the end
of blood origin is saved from the temerians the
elves probably eventually take him back to this
area near the woods near the sheraweed which might
be where he runs into geralt again in present day
during season three she's still trained to be a
Witcher not much time has gone by but she's also
been training in her magecraft learning to use her
magic powers through Elder blood like she started
to open gates at the end of season two she'll
continue to learn more about that which is where I
think we get to the idea of her using the gates to
time travel we'll learn more about vilgafort's
working with Emperor emhyr even though both of
them have their own agenders for wanting Ciri but
the real big thing that everybody is talking about
mostly is Henry Cavill leaving as geralt like why
is he leaving the show why did he quit The Witcher
there were a lot of people claiming all kinds
of crazy things were happening behind the scenes
without the showrunner confirming any of this
it sounds like what happened is that there were
some creative differences in Henry Cavill isn't a
producer on the show like he's just an actor for
hire just like a Hired Gun he's incredibly highly
paid and it's harder for him to do movies while
he's doing The Witcher like it actually takes
them a good long while to film Witcher Seasons
even though it's only eight episodes so it sounded
like a Confluence of events where he wanted to
do other projects like he wanted to do other
movies like he just announced that he's doing
the Warhammer series I did a big trailer video
for that because he released a teaser trailer
so I'll post a link for that at the end of this
where he'll be the executive producer he'll have
much more of a say in what's actually happening
during the series in the Warhammer movies that
they're developing and he's always gone on about
how precious he is about The Witcher like he's a
huge fan of The Witcher books and it sounds like
there were some disagreements behind the scenes
about some of the changes they were making with
the show with the geralt character and since he's
not a producer on The Witcher show basically he
has to do whatever the producers say the writers
say and since the further the series goes on the
more and more Netflix has to pay him he probably
just started asking for more and more money that
they did not want to pay him so that's probably
why they agreed to part ways like okay I have
other projects that I can actually do whatever
I want to with like they'll be my own projects
and I can earn way more money it'll have a little
more control over his time so he can actually
do other projects as well too like he won't be
locked down to The Witcher schedule as crazy as
it all sounds usually that's why stars as big as
him wind up leaping shows like this even though
it seems like he could have gone on for many more
seasons and he'd said that he was willing to go on
for many more seasons usually just comes down to
time money and control over what's happening
with your character but the way the show is
going it sounds like they plan to do season four
with Liam Hemsworth like they already announced
Liam Hemsworth was taking over in season four
for the girl character in season five depending
on how Season 4 goes will probably wind up being
there last season like they'll probably wrap it
up by season five when they release more trailer
footage the showrunner starts talking more about
what was actually going on behind the scenes with
Henry Cavill of course I'll do more videos about
that everyone click here for that brand new Henry
Cavill Warhammer trailer video really excited to
see what he does with that series and everyone
click here for that brand new Flash trailer
video thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and I'll see you guys in the next one!